federal student loan debt hit 1.6  trillion dollars last year  this is a major problem for people in  their 20s and 30s but the federal  government simply wiping their debt  clean is just about the stupidest way to  address it when bernie sanders was  running for president he promised that  he would forgive student loan debt  altogether which would mean printing  more than a trillion dollars thus  driving up inflation and bringing the  federal government even closer to  insolvency  president biden has said that he wants  to forgive ten thousand dollars per  borrower but in the meantime he has been  using his executive authority to whittle  away at the debt load including a recent  85 billion dollar expansion of loan  forgiveness programs  [Music]